crossing the channel is the dangerous
part of coming to britain illegally but
once here many migrants tell us the
process of claiming asylum is nothing
like they imagined
we've gained an insight into a system
that appears overwhelmed well over a
hundred thousand asylum claims are
currently being dealt with including 32
year old journalist hushang armin and
iraqi kurd
after waiting in a camp in northern
france four months ago like thousands of
others he paid smugglers to bring him
across the channel by boat
huxiang speaks five languages including
english which makes him a popular figure
amongst the other migrants he lives with
in a hotel he tells us many find the
system too difficult to navigate by
themselves most of them they need help
and i will help them always because they
they can't speak english that's a big
problem of refugees for bank account for
nhs for gp for doctor
for home office sometimes they have a
big problem sometimes they run into my
room
doing like that when i open the door
they say please that's english
organization that is gp can you help do
you think some people get lost in the
system exactly
yes most of them to find out what it's
like to be stuck in the asylum system we
went to two different places in the
north of england to speak to migrants
and local residents we're not revealing
exactly where and this is why look as
you can see there's lots and lots of
migrants there
it's absolutely outrageous that we're
paying for this
absolute shocking this is videos like
this have been uploaded as recently as
august by the far-right group britain
first angry the uk government is
providing asylum seekers with food and
somewhere to live whilst their claims
are being processed
hi guys
what country is all from hi
are you staying in this hotel the
extremists have been targeting migrant
accommodation to make their voices heard
asylum seekers are not allowed to work
whilst their applications are being
processed but the number waiting more
than six months for a decision has gone
up tenfold in the last decade leaving
the applicants increasingly rudderless
and as we found that can sometimes put a
strain on relations with the local
community
peter lives near the hotel we visited
housing asylum seekers he says the
migrants should be sent back to their
own country although i was thinking for
my kid's safety i mean when you see them
walking around here and that's like a
park but i think my kids don't park and
i don't like to think i don't know they
are where they're from
and stuff you know what i mean but
there's no evidence that anyone's caused
any problems yeah i know what you're
saying yeah but it's just my opinion as
well where to house asylum seekers is a
minefield we went to a complex in the
leafy suburbs of another city
illustrating the lottery of the housing
dilemma
after they arrive in the uk asylum
seekers are dispersed around the country
they can end up in all sorts of
accommodation whether it's a repurposed
empty building shared housing or a hotel
i know people that have been in the
asylum process for several years and
have been moved round three or four uk
cities
i have
no family here we met bazaar from iran
separated from his friend who he crossed
the channel with nine months ago
i was i live in ronkon sometimes i come
here visit from my friend because i'm
alone in the city you know but however
wearing the process it doesn't seem to
be deterring the migrants
very difficult life from before
i this now is better thank you for god
thank you for england for government
england for the people helping for the
people
we were given this footage by asylum
seekers living in a former army barracks
in the south of england
they're sleeping areas separated by
curtains
those who fled conflict say being sent
to an ex-military site is difficult to
deal with psychologically it's another
glimpse into a system which campaigners
say desperately needs to be overhauled
the way to stop the delays is to process
the cranes of the people who are
entitled to asylum and get them working
they didn't ask to be put in hotels for
months what they want is to work and get
on with their lives the faster we get
them doing that the more we don't have
the delays and have people in the
hotels migrants are elated when they
finally set foot on british soil but
still ahead navigating a system which
even the government admits is broken
the home office says it takes the
well-being of asylum seekers and the
communities in which they live extremely
seriously and is determined to clear the
backlog of applications
some face lengthy appeals and whilst the
risk of deportation is low the
unsuccessful may end up living in the uk
illegally never actually part of a
society they risk their lives to try to
join lisa holland sky news